♪ (JAZZY PERCUSSION PLAYING) ♪
-(KNOCKING ON DOOR)
-Hi. Checking in?
KATHRYN SIDDELL-BAUERS:
It's Walt's forty-fifth
birthday soirée.
-(BOTTLES CLINK)
-ALL: Cheers.
This place has its own magic.
I think you're gonna love it.
-You smell nice.
- (WHISPERS) Okay...
GEORGE:
This is such a great spread.
You want a wiener?
Watch your fingers.
-Honey?
-Eww.
It's nice to get away
and unplug.
-Guys, eyes on me.
-(GROUP HOLLERS PLAYFULLY)
I am the only
certified lifeguard present,
so please keep an eye on me.
This place is just so relaxing.
Time to get our buns in gear
for our fossil hunt.
She always has a plan,
my Katty.
Today, we have
birds of prey watching! Whoo!
♪ (JAZZY BASS LINE PLAYING) ♪
It's nice to get a break
from the group, right?
NINA-JOY:
Honestly, I just need a drink.
We're doing
whatever the "F" we want.
♪ I love the mountains ♪
-♪ I love the rolling hills ♪
-(JANDICE MOANS SEXUALLY)
Kathryn!
Why is your face so tight?
Did you put on a night cream?
♪ Boom de yada, boom de yada ♪
♪ Boom de yadda, boom de yada ♪
-HARRY: What's her diagnosis?
-She's mentally quite sound.
-Okay.
-F-you!
♪ I love the flowers ♪
KATHRYN:
The weird thing about life,
you can feel fine, but also,
know you're a ticking time bomb.
(BOTTLE TINKS)
Where... are... we?!
Why do you have to be
so controlling about everything?
Take that! Take that! Take that!
-(SLAP)
-Ugh!
I just wanna say...
I'm now ready to forgive
all of you.
♪ Boom de yada, boom de yada ♪